do you have a favorite twitch streamer
while soon you'll be able to buy games
right from their streams I'm Tony this
is a GameSpot news update and for plenty
of awesome live streams from us be sure
to subscribe this spring
twitch will start selling PC games
you'll be able to buy them directly from
the site and launch them through
Twitch's own desktop app or other
publisher apps like Ubisoft's you play
and when you buy from within your
favorite streamers show they'll get a
cut seems like a good way to support the
streamers you love while also adding to
your own collection
Ubisoft Telltale Games and hi-rez
Studios are some of the first publishers
to sign up for the new program online
retailer Amazon acquired twitch in 2014
so this game selling could be the start
of even more new programs if you're in
the mood for live shows you can tune
into the lobby every Wednesday at 11
a.m. pacific for our takes on all the
newest games and for all the latest
gaming news you're already in the right
place